[Music]
all right let's go out to Bend Oregon
not bend over but Bend Oregon and talk
to Elise what's up
Elise hi Dr John um doing good hi Dr
John can you hear me doing good I can
yeah I can hear you
great okay so um I appreciate you taking
my call I been really stressed for the
past year it seems like um what's going
on my my question is am I in a
emotionally abusive relationship and
controlling relationship or is this all
just a misunderstanding and I'm actually
the problem okay hold on before you ask
I want to know what you
think actually not even what you think
like put your hand on your on your belly
right now on your tummy what does your
gut tell
you um my gut tells me there's something
very wrong here but I keep holding on to
Maybe not maybe I
just don't know what a good relationship
should be like ah okay so before you
tell me what's going
on have you ever had reason to doubt
you
um in yeah in relationships absolutely
okay so your self-doubt is is well
earned you've made mistakes in the past
and you don't think you're very
trustworthy right
now
um just maybe my level of maturity or um
how I react to situations might be my my
biggest issue that I need to work on
okay that's super fair man that's very
self-aware of you that's awesome all
right so what's going on that you're
wondering am I the
problem
so um I've been with my boyfriend for a
year and a half um he's very very
attentive which is one of the things
that Drew me to him I don't think guys
are usually that attentive as he is um
so I felt for the luck like as the
luckiest girl alive um for a while um
but a little bit into to dating
um
he I I guess I wouldn't communicate with
him enough and by that I mean I would
wake up in the morning and go to work
sometimes and I wouldn't say good
morning right away I would say good
morning at 9:00 a.m. instead of 8 or
instead of at 7 when I woke up and um
were youall are youall living together
or were you just in your own apartment
and you would just go to
work yeah just in my own apartment and I
would go to work you know just going
about normal life things and
um he needs to be in constant constant
communication constant communication
like the moment I wake up I need to talk
to him and um uh early on in our
relationship he almost broke up with me
because he said he felt like an
afterthought and to me that was wild
because he's the only person that I
would spend any time with we would see
each other almost every day I would Comm
communicate text with him you know daily
constantly and so when he told me that
and he was about to break up with me
because he felt like an afterthought I
tripled down on the amount of um
attention that I would give him you know
and I just made sure that I was in
constant communication I mean every 5 to
10 minutes I kid you not um to me it
seems excessive but I thought okay maybe
if I do this he'll feel a little bit
more secure in the relationship he's
been burned before he's been cheated on
y y so I want to make him feel secure
and see that I'm all in that I'm all
about him and he doesn't have to worry
um but after a while he he moved the
Finish Line
right I'm sorry he just moved the finish
line yes yeah after a while I noticed
that it just no matter how much effort I
would put in he would still be like
really suspicious of me of everything
that I would do and even if he knew I
was at home just sitting at home doing
chores or whatever he wanted me to list
out exactly all the things that I was
doing at least run run run run and I
hate to say that to you because I know
that you like this person and I know
that you're invested in this person I
wish you could see the eyes of the women
that are looking at me right now they
look like
saucers like wide
eyy that's what everybody tells me yes
and here's here's what I want to here's
the most important thing about what
you're what what you're walking through
and it has absolutely nothing to do with
him okay I want to take him completely
out of
it especially in the first six months
you really liked this guy didn't you
yeah absolutely like you grow really be
the one you yeah you started making
plans with this guy like secretly right
you had like you started developing
pictures of oh this is going to be like
right yeah and you expressed that in a
way that was whole and good for
you you really fell for
somebody yeah and they looked at you and
said you're not
enough the way you feel whole and good
is not enough for
me you you have to be
more yeah and I'm talking about um this
could be text messages you have to text
me 15 times a day I text you five times
a day I text nobody in my life nobody
and I text you five right 20 minutes go
by and he'll question it that's right
and that can be sexual that can be
Financial that can be um questioning
every second of you like everything
about you and the reason I
when you said I tripled down and I kind
of held my breath cuz I was almost
positive what was going to happen if it
had been
you now here's like a the push back I'm
going to get from people listening is
this when I got married to my
wife I didn't know certain things I
didn't know you have to wash your sheets
once a month good grief are we crazy
right I didn't know and my wife told
me like hey and my house we're going to
wash our sheets every week cuz you're
gross and I was like okay
awesome and I came towards right there
was a Finish Line there this is what
we're going to do and I was like awesome
I'm in
it when you said you triple
down he moved the Finish Line on you all
right fine I'm going to text you 15
times a day and then within a week or
two 15 times isn't enough now I want to
see your text I want to GPS locate you
on my phone I want because what he's
trying to do is use you to fill some
sort of void he's
got yep you are a drug you're a Xanax
for him and he's got to keep taking more
and more and more and more and he
doesn't care if it kills you in the
process that's what it feels like
definitely it is and I could hear you
talking is you don't talk about this
enough out loud with your friends
because I could hear as you were talking
it was finally all starting to come out
a little bit
right yeah I've started hiding it from
people the extent of it please don't
please don't can I ask you
why um like let's say let's say you call
him today and break
up and there's that deep
grief what do you what's scary about
that moment for you cuz it's deeper than
just a breakup for
you
um uh I don't know just I was just
really holding on to the idea that I
could have something good with him but
sometimes I think if we were to break up
I would be a lot I would be hurting for
a while but I'd ultimately be doing a
lot
better
do you believe
that because I think you're worth a lot
better whatever that looks
like yeah and I'm telling you to run I'm
not in the business of breaking up
relationships and so if you want to stay
here's your only path
forward a sitdown conversation where you
say I love you we've been together for a
year and a half
and a you've got to go do your own work
because I can't be responsible for
making you feel better it's not my
job number two I will text you three
times a day period and if that's not
good enough for you then we're done then
you are choosing to not be in
relationship with
me I will tell you where I'm like when
I'm headed out with my friends you're
not going to geolocate me on your
phone you're not going to come by my
house in the middle of the night and
check on my car you're not going to go
through my text and you're not going to
go through my
receipts and if that's not okay if you
need that to be whole then you're
choosing to not be in relationship with
me because I can't live like
this because you're like being you're
like being like your your dating
relationship is like
a I was watching Homeland last week when
I was sick like it's it's like a CIA
investigation all the time 247 365 those
are exhausting right mhm yeah I'm under
scrutiny yeah have you cheated on him
Elise no no are you hiding money from
him absolutely not I don't believe you
of course you're not
right and you should not have to spend
every second of your life as though you
are you get to decide whether I'm
staying or going I'm going to ask you
with all my heart I'm not going to beg
you but I'm going to get really
close you know you're in an unsafe
relationship whether it's physical
whether it's sexually unsafe or whether
it is psychologically or emotionally
unsafe when you start when you start
hiding parts of it from your closest
friends when you stop telling the truth
to the people who you know have your
best interest at
heart when you have that little lash of
I think everything in my life would be
better it would suck for a while but
everything in my life would be better if
this was if this was
gone I want you to put your hand on your
belly and feel that and believe it
because I think you're
right I think you're right and if you
choose to stay I want you to be really
honest about what you need not the
triple down version plus the triple
downtimes 2 * 8 not that version I want
you to be really firm about what you
believe and what you you need to be
whole and I want you to put that on the
table and say this is who you're
with this is what I'm worth and this is
what I need I can't keep living under an
investigation under
microscope and maybe he'll go oh my gosh
I'm you're right I'm going to go to
counseling and I'm going to get better
but I think you and I both know probably
not make a call but I want you to make
the call knowing
this you're worth something better than
what you're experiencing right now
and I hope for the first time in a long
time you'll listen to that voice way
down deep trying to keep Elise
safe and reach out to your friends and
start telling them the truth hey guys
this isn't getting better it's actually
getting worse I need somebody to hold my
hand through this process because I
think it's going to be kind of
Rocky but you're worth being loved and
that means you're worth being whole and
you're worth telling the truth